so I'm going to be talking this morning
about an infection to autism this is
only an introduction we're going to hit
it very lightly but I'm delighted to be
here to talk and we'll have a chance as
I mentioned for this group to have
questions later I should just mention my
conflicts of interest which are a grant
of which Akasha is the principal
investigator along with a number of
books and I also edit the Journal of
autism this book in particular I would
mention whoops and I lost that book
because I did something on the page oh
my gosh oh please don't start on me
slide show back to the current slide
that's what I get for messing for method
with the thing I'm not going to touch it
anymore the book of the top corner of
the right is a third edition of a book
that I originally got started for my
undergraduate class from Cambridge
University Press
and it's just come out in a third
edition and it's relatively inexpensive
so I'm gonna talk a little bit about
autism in terms of diagnostic concept a
little bit of an overview of the field
and something about diagnosis and then
move on to key findings from research
and then talk about outcomes and
treatment and finally our current needs
and some social policy issues which is a
fascinating area so development of the
field the origins of this really
antedates both Connor and Asperger if
you look starting with the work of Itard
and France at the end of the 17th
century early 18th century his reports
on victor the wild boy
interest in so-called feral children
children who presumably were being weird
by animals most of those children
probably had autism if you read the
reports that Victor he had no language
had low unusual behaviors he probably
either eloped from his parents or was
abandoned and then showed up in e [ __ ]
that people assumed this romantic notion
of animals taking care of children if
they were found in the wild which I can
tell you would not happen they would be
food and point effect was the possible
exception of dogs animals are not
children like animals but it's
interesting that we probably can see the
first reports that show with autism at
that point then it's the 1800s and the
book on the top corner here in a
different key is a wonderful history of
autism these people tracked down
honors first patient donald and who was
still alive at that point may still be
he's in his 80s if so and they actually
don't talk to him but they also pointed
out that the 1800s
some of the institutions in
Massachusetts that took children with
what we now would think of as
intellectual disability mental
retardation many of the cases described
were cases where it sounds like the
child had autism then the point of view
however actually defining autism first
describing as credit goes to lis
O'Connor the first American child
psychiatrist or refugee from Germany he
was at Hopkins and he talked about
eleven cases of children who had two
things one was autism living in their
own world not being socially connected
and the other thing was what he told
called resistance to change we'll talk
more about that resistance to change
actually meant several things that
literal trouble with change having
trouble and to take the same route every
day to go to the big wire stop and shop
any deviation the kid fell it fell apart
same thing changing around the furniture
in the room kind of mentioned some of
his patients as they would come back
will be upset with him because he had
changed how his office was arranged but
this insistence on sameness also meant a
tendency for the child to use routines
and Conner actually as part of that same
package included some of the unusual
behaviors and mannerisms the stereotyped
body movements they hand flapping he saw
that as an attempt of the child's part
to maintain sameness in the environment
so the interesting thing here is he's
talking about this interesting paradox
on the one hand these are children who
are not social included but they're
hyper clued into the non social
environment and we're gonna try to
understand more about that as we talked
today
a year later hands Asperger who was a
medical student in Vienna and he was in
during the war he was in Austria not in
nazi-occupied Austria he talked about a
group of boys who had something he
called
autistic personality disorder and again
it's been translated various ways from
the German that's probably the best way
to translate it these were boys who had
self-centered qualities but they didn't
show up until the kids in her preschool
and they would hug inappropriately other
kids didn't know who they were
these were boys who had unusual
interests they often pursue their
interest with great intensity to the
point where it interfered
they're learning of other things which
is a key point because it's that
interference with learning that moves it
into being a disorder and he also
pointed out that the families had
revolved their family life revolved
around the child's special interest a
kid who's interested in trains they'd
have to go the train station decieded
the 6:15 live scene from Leipzig get in
on time and so he talked about these
kids again having autistic personality
problems he did not see this as a
developmental disorder effectively these
two descriptions sent the stage for
what's a continuing debate the tension
between the broad view and the narrow
view the broad view as we'll talk about
is supported somewhat by the genetics
which is identified many genes
potentially many gene variants which
means there's probably a lot of other
combinations of genes out there or
people are able to be a little strange
or will hyper focus but they don't have
autism on the contrast the narrow view
of the connor view is a classic
childhood autism and this is the tension
that continues today and we'll talk a
little bit about with dsm so the big
accomplishments 1950s and 60s quite
frankly not much happened things started
to happen in the 70s as children autism
were followed in the 50s and 60s as
we'll talk about within the ESM these
were children who regard as having
childhood schizophrenia and that was
because that were autism people ah
autism we know that words one of the
forays the boiler used to describes
could Sabri talked about self-centered
thinking that's not what was being
talked about here these were children
who came into the world without a
predisposition to connect with people
but that was a term that was used it was
very much impossible to sort all this
out because the children childhood
schizophrenia which turns out to be
extremely rare but people really had no
good ideas one of the sad things
unfortunately was people in the 50s and
60s will talk about started blaming the
parents for the child's problem and
we'll talk about the history of this
which is very interesting in the 1970s
however several things happened one was
an awareness as children over time they
had a very high risk for seizures about
20% of children with classic autism will
develop seizures of various kinds
usually major motor of grand mal
seizures various points in development
early childhood and also adolescence
which otherwise is an extremely rare
for people to first develop seizures the
other thing was in the late seventies
the first wind study came out there had
been a paper a few months before that
basically two prominent geneticists that
said there's no genetics taught ISM and
in the first ones do they came out which
said there's tremendous genetics the
first one study was done the United
Kingdom Susan falstein and Michael
Rutter they looked at same sex fraternal
twin pairs and the reason they looked at
same sex is there's a gender issue of
bias and autism and then identical twin
pairs and they discovered among the
identical twins whose amazing highly
cortical cord so if you had an identical
twin with autism you were very very
likely to have autism not so among the
fraternal twins and their first study
which is pretty small the risk was about
the same as in the population we
actually know that now it's it's
actually somewhat higher that there was
an increased risk for fraternal twins
but not nearly as much as identical
twins and finally in the 1970s the first
studies came out that showed structured
education behavioral approaches were
more effective and unstructured
psychotherapy which until that time had
been the only treatment let me say a
word or two about DSM DSM one and two
are largely of historical interest
they're very theoretically based they
have their own biases part of the
problem with having a theoretically
based diagnostic system is if you don't
mind of the theory kind of screwed and
it's a problem and so the big change in
DSM 3 which I give Bob Spitzer whose
picture is here on the side great credit
for Bob Spitzer who was part of the
Washington University School and st.
Louis who moved to Columbia and they
were very very focused in developing
what they called research diagnostic
criteria this was a real change in
psychiatry when DSM 3 came out it really
revolutionized the field and DSM 3
autism was included for the first time
it was called infantile autism it was
grouped under a class of disorders
called pervasive developmental disorders
that came up with this term out of
nowhere because it had no history and
you know in retrospect they could have
used a better term autism in really good
conditions but they didn't they used
this funny term pervasive developmental
disorder but autism was included the
trouble with the first definition was it
very much was a definition of infantile
autism
it was mono thetic which we
you had to meet all the criteria
pervasive lack of responsiveness we know
that as children get older with autism
they do respond they do develop some
social skills especially if they have
intervention and often those are odd
blah blah blah but it's not pervasive so
there was a funny category of DSM C
called residual infantile autism which
was very problematic because the
residual problems weren't so residual
would you met these kids and adolescents
and adults so minute major changes were
made in the next iteration DSM 3r which
came up fairly quickly we moved from
infantile autism autistic disorder and
now all of a sudden we have the poly
thetic description of the diagnostic
criteria some from a some from be some
from see social communication and
resistance to change and this was again
a big change because all of a sudden you
can have different combinations that
could get you a diagnosis of autistic
disorder it was much better in terms of
approaching the whole range of the
syndrome probably over diagnosed among
the more severely intellectually
disabled then we had DSM 4 this was done
in conjunction with ICD 10 icd-10 is the
world system of diagnosis technically
speaking we are DSM as regarded as a
regional variant I believe and of course
DSM has captured the field and did back
in 1980 so around the world that's what
people used but ICD the International
classification of diseases which is
based in Geneva
part of the World Health Organization by
treaty were obligated to have a
connection with ICD and that means those
funny codes when you go to the hospital
you have pneumonia there's a code that's
an ICD code and so des Simmons were
related to ICD around these codes but
for during the DSM and the ICD at the
time that we were involved doing it and
I was in charge the DSM part of it and
Mike Rutter was doing the icd-10 part of
it and we agreed you know this is crazy
we don't need to have two diagnostic
systems one for America and one for the
rest of the world
we need one system as we can possibly do
it this had all kinds of complications
and other issues which I won't get into
but anyway in the end we did a lot of
bells and whistles and we did a big
field trial over a hundred Raiders
nearly a thousand cases 20-some sites
around the world
over a year and we came up with a new
definition that was essentially the same
for GSM for icd-10 this was around for
almost 20 years and it worked extremely
well as you'll see when we have I'll
show you some of the research data in
terms of research papers there was just
an explosion of research now let me say
a word about dsm-5 and you can sort of
get my take on it up at the top
unfortunately I'm sorry to say dsm-5 was
well motivated I was early early on I
was part of the process and I along with
some other people resigned because we
didn't like the way it was going they
included a new category autism spectrum
disorder great in terms of name change
another new disorder called social
communication disorder which had
basically no or very little rational
basis but it was sort of thrown in there
I think because they were rightly
worried about not including some
children when there was no longer sub
threshold categories what we called the
past pdd-nos or atypical autism that's
all gone so the criteria we had two
rather than three categories social
communication and resistance to change
and this was done the basis of looking
at a big body of data from the a toss at
the ADI doing factor analyses and other
kinds of things and the trouble of
factor analyses and I can tell you this
from looking at the DSM for David you
can come up I can tell you what the DSM
for day you could have a tooth and
solution or three effective solution or
a five factor solution
take your pick depending on which we
feel like works best again I don't want
to oversimplify it but it's it is kind
of you taking your pick and we went with
the three factor 18 years some before
because we thought it gave us more
flexibility and they went with two
factors basically in dsm-5 social
communication resistance to change we
reduced our number of criteria we had a
number of criteria and DSM for that I
think over 2000 combinations and
permutations could get to a diagnosis of
autistic disorder and DSM 4 so it was
whatever else was true there were a lot
of ways to get in all of a sudden we
went from two thousand to twelve and
some funny way that's all you need to
know in terms of what the issues are
with dsm-5
so there's some good news the good news
is the recognition of this order that's
great
the bad and unexpected news perhaps is
that despite the name change to autism
spectrum disorder the concept is more
narrowly defined and there's been a
series of papers I'm going to show you
one that's there been a couple of meta
analyses that now show this my colleague
Jimmy McPartland here in I am Brian
Reich cow who was then here and is now
an associate professor down in Florida
looked at the old DSM for data what we
could find about 30 cases have been lost
in a flood let me warn you about what to
around here but we're able to recode
these data and we went back and did that
looked at them and then we we we
programmed em for dsm-5 and we've
discovered a very interesting thing it
was very specific but the trouble was
who it left out and here's what happened
to the cases and what you can see here
is among the high functioning people
with autism by clinical diagnosis a fair
number almost 50 percent lost their
label but look at Asperger's and P gos
most of them moves their label this was
not happy news this came out this
literally was featured the front page
the New York Times and of course what's
the problem in this country you lose
your label what do you lose services and
so this was not happy news so but this
time the DSM folks had more or less
wrapped it up and they had to add a new
criteria which was if you're okay if you
already haven't well-established
diagnosis of autism Asperger's be heroes
you can keep it so that was the solution
which is back to my trainwreck business
it's like we've got two trains running
on the same track
and it's problematic and I'm sure this
will be addressed in dsm-5 point one
whenever it shows up let me say a little
bit about research or what we know
genetics we know this tremendous genetic
factors in autism I'm going to say
something about so social brain and
interventions and a little bit to show
you that we think actually our
interventions are producing better
outcomes research has increased in terms
of just literally the number of papers
and the number of journals that I think
there are over 20 journals now that have
autism in the title I'm the editor of
the journal of autism developmental
disorders which is the first one when I
first took over and up now about ten
years ago we had about 300 papers come
in every year from
you I think last year we had close to
1500 papers which is just a tremendous
number and you can imagine I've gone
from having me and two associators to me
in about bazillion associate editors but
let me say a little bit about this shows
you the research early on and this is
grouped by five year blocks except for
the first block so you can see that by
1992 95 we had over five years about
1200 papers so that's a little over 1200
divided by five right that's so bad you
can keep up with it but look at what's
happened more recently I don't have a 18
data yet it takes a little while to get
them but you can see they were close to
4,000 papers a year so how are you gonna
keep up that's it's I mean it's good
news and it's bad news because it's a
problem in terms of just being able to
master the literature why is research
increased were the several reasons first
of all there's a lot of basic
fundamental interest in autism because
it's a prototypical example of a
disorder involving the social brain
there's a whole body of work on this I'm
going to show you a little bit brothers
was the first one to talk about the
social brain and really talked a lot
about autism and you're gonna hear a lot
here at the Child Study Center about
social neuroscience it seems to also be
very interesting because we can reap
attention the brain and genes and
behavior together and understand more
about fundamentally what makes us as
people social what makes us so social
there's also social political reasons
parent groups and foundations have just
tremendously increased in terms of
number and their levels of support for
research which is fantastic lesson
speaks the autism Science Foundation the
Simons Foundation which is probably
funding more research than the federal
government is at the moment but it's
just really a tribute to the fact that
parents who used to be afraid of talking
about having a child with autism they
said no no we're gonna work on this
we're gonna fix it we're gonna we'll go
tackle it which is fantastic
finally there's financial reasons and
people know Willie Sutton if people know
who Willie Sutton was is a famous law
and medicine called Sutton's law
Sutton's rule Willie Sutton was a bank
robber and Willie Sutton whose pictures
here they once asked Willie why he
robbed banks because
that's where the money is well so the
interesting thing here is as money has
increased in terms of research of course
people are on people who have previously
no interest all of a sudden they have an
interest in autism and I'll talk a
little bit about the Internet it's got
good news and bad news but there's no
question there's more media attention I
just saw something like a Good Morning
America last week which was a great ad
for some lovely place that also talked
about some slightly unusual treatments
but you know for good news and bad news
we've got the interest in this and the
internet we'll talk about so
understanding autism what is autism and
this movie did a lot to get people in
this country aware of autism where a man
autism is first and foremost a disorder
of social interaction included including
unusual patterns of learning and over
engagement with a non social world so
what happens if you have a social frame
if you come into the world and you're
ready to play the social game right what
happens you pay attention to people
you're paying attention to their faces
especially you pay attention to what
they're looking at you learn from just
watching what they're looking at if
something is dangerous or safe you look
to your mom or dad is it dangerous or
safe you pay attention to their language
we were just talking about language
learning language becomes very
interesting early on kids with autism
because all kids have produced a range
of sounds some of which they're not
going to be in their their language that
they speak but they lose those sounds
because they don't hear them it's with
autism sometimes have persisting very
unusual sounds that never would
otherwise be used for example in the
English language they develop prosody
before 912 months
there's singsong back and forth it's
english prosody they would prefer
English prosody if they're growing up in
an english-speaking household so it's a
whole very interesting package of stuff
and we don't send children to language
school it's one of the major proofs as I
was talking with my colleagues earlier
of the existence of God that children
really do learn language on their own
and they're very very good at it
so even before the child is saying their
first words they're having these proto
conversations with their parents they're
having about the same turn lengths
they're going back and forth there's an
expectation of this is my turn this is
your turn this doesn't happen or not
but this happens if you have a social
frame I can remember my first child we
just had our first grandchild and when
she was born she was two weeks late it
was a long labor and delivery and my
wife handed up having a c-section and
she spiked a temperature and she was a
pediatrician there's a zillion docs in
the room and so she has her c-section I
checked that she's okay and then I go
off to newborn special care to see my
new daughter who's just been delivered
and walked in and I said can I hold my
daughter and of course there's this big
baby so where am i all these tiny babies
and I hold her and she's looked at me
and I'm looking at her and we're off and
running and still are and it's really
amazing to see this happen so let me ask
you a couple questions what's more
interesting this or this I would argue
that you can't pull yourself away from
looking at the faces and part of the
reason for that is we have a tendency
issue is to seek the face so look at all
these pictures I think you see a face in
all of them right and none of these are
human people these are houses these are
bowling balls eggplants but isn't it
interesting and so I say in some funny
way for people with autism children with
autism it's sort of like looking at this
picture
how many Navy SEALs are hidden in this
picture take a look and make a guess and
I'll show you a ton but think about if
you came into the world and you couldn't
make up people from this round that's
gonna cause some troubles so if you put
it another way if you come to the role
with the social frame people are the
center of your world you're learning
from them all the time you're focused on
them all the time you have something
called joint attention your mom looks at
something you look at something you
follow what they're looking at you have
incidental learning you have the
development of effect and emotions and
it's helped you'll help to regulate how
you interact with your parents and back
and forth you also have a strong desire
to communicate because it's so efficient
in getting your message across and
people are the most important things in
the world so again an autism it's
different and we want to know a little
bit about what we can understand
social development early on especially
in relation to the brain but how this
affects children autism and their
interaction so let me show you very
quickly get in typical development
there's a very strong attraction to face
from birth we're able to see very very
clearly markers of this dreamy
McPartland who's on the faculty here
his first seminal work was on looking at
faces and discovering a very
characteristic EEG phenomena and looking
at faces which I'll show you in one
second and here we go here's Jamie and a
baby and here's someone doing the EEG
which are these are much easier to do
these days and when I first got to the
field you're just what the hair and put
on those bases a little funny cap you're
off and running but the interesting
thing that jamie has pointed out is this
when you average many of these things
for looking at faces kids with autism
because without autism you find this and
this is called the n170 because it's
negative and it's 170 milliseconds out
for people looking at faces there's a
very characteristic response and it's
specific to faces but look at the people
with autism it's slower and it's not the
same so how can we understand this this
is a study Bob Schultz and a group of us
did some years ago looking at faces
versus objects happily this has been
replicated many many times now we showed
people lying in the MRI machine so it's
magnetic no radiation one button for
same what but one button for different
same or different same or different same
or different same or different faces and
objects and the idea so we're going to
compare and contrast or does the blood
flow go for objects versus faces and
again what we see is for the typical
folks there's an area called the
fusiform gyrus which was right about
here or both most of us right under the
ears on the bottom side of the face that
is a specialized face recognition area
for people who are typical that lights
up we get more blood flowing there but
not so for the people with autism and
Asperger's and again these were high
functioning people interestingly enough
we had one one of our students one of
our trainees had one we had one child
with a very strong interest in the
pokemons for Pokemon that area would
light up and the Pokemon was in contrast
to faces including family member faces
so again it's not that that area didn't
work it didn't work for the faces which
tells us there's something different
about the wiring
which is another very interesting thing
this was a Yale undergraduate project
from one of my students in one of my
classes who came to me and said he
wanted to do this study on eye tracking
and I said well I don't know I'd seen an
eye tracking setup in the Netherlands
and you had to put the person's head in
a vise
you had to paste things around then I
thought oh my this is never gonna work
for a person with autism he said no no
the technology's got much better and on
McLin who was that he ran I managed to
raise a little money to help him build
this $20,000 baseball cap and at that
point I tracking had not been done in
autism and all he had been a little bit
in children from looking at a movement
in reading problems and dyslexia had
been done in schizophrenia looking at
again at eye movements but nystagmus but
not so much in looking at what the
person was looking at and so we looked
at this for the first time we took some
little five-second clips very short
clips from a very intense movie and
involved really only four people it was
black and white because we at that point
didn't know what color was going to do
to it and this is a nice movie about a
pleasant dinner party among four two
couples faculty it's a do England
College called Who's Afraid of Virginia
Woolf and for those of you who have not
seen this this is a very intense movie
and these people just tear each other up
right it's like it's like a Greek
tragedy but the interesting thing is we
show little clips from this movie and
here you can see the lovely Emily vote
board demonstrating for $10 which she
negotiated up from five and she's
watching this she's got a very tiny
little camera on her hat when uh one
camera is pointing that way one camera
is pointing this way it's infrared so
she can't see it but we could actually
track based on her what what her retinas
looking at the most sensitive part of
the retina
what's she really focusing on in the
see and I'm going to show you data from
our first two people a man with autism
who's independent and self-sufficient
but who very much has autism and a
typical viewer who's not quite as bright
and here we go this is about five
seconds of the movie condensed onto a
single frame okay at the top you see
that typical viewer back and forth to
the eyes and the bottom you see the
person with autism back and forth to the
mouth the interesting thing very quickly
as a total aside when my daughter is
doing this we were doing this for a
German television crew and the Chi so
she did it because they showed up and
said we want a child I said I can't get
you a child I'll see my god we'll do it
and they say oh hi this is wonderful
wonderful wonderful now show us you had
autism and she said dad what am I
supposed to do at this point we were
very early on this I said sweetie look
at the objects and so she immediately
looks at this point keep in mind I have
seen this movie a hundred times to pick
up the clips what does she find in this
movie that I'd never seen see in the top
corner there's a map of Martha's
Vineyard which I'm going to tomorrow she
had been going through all her life I've
been going since 1980 I had never seen
that man because of course I'm looking
at these people who are tearing each
other up and the interesting thing here
is the ceilin movie something scary has
happened it looks like the husband's
coming out to shoot his wife he's got a
gun I'll puffs and umbrella haha big
joke on everyone but the couple doesn't
know that yet but you see where the
typical viewer goes straight to the eyes
and the person with autism goes straight
to the mouth the trouble with this is if
you're sort of an eye person versus a
mouth person the eye folks get about 90%
of the social life effective information
the mouth is much less this actually has
held up pretty well in meta-analyses the
eye business especially the mouth
business is a little more variable about
I think that's probably more
methodological than anything but in our
first series of cases this is now larger
series of cases you can see here there's
no overlap in terms of looking at the
eyes there's something called Cohen's
which is an estimate of the strength the
effect size the Cohen's D here is three
points something it's a whopping effect
you know usually a treatment stage we
get a point seven point eight we think
oh this is great but this is what we're
against in terms of the treatment it's
the severity of this social problem so
it's all this mean in terms of outcome
well the interesting thing is as we've
gotten more aware of what the needs are
and the special intervention challenges
but also the needs for structure
teaching we've gotten more effective
programs increased awareness has also
led to earlier diagnosis you hear from
kosheh were very interested in autism
and very young children and we think
there's probably now a better outcome as
children have gotten earlier and earlier
interventions I'm going to show you some
data on that and we're interested
because we think here especially we want
to integrate clinical work with research
now let me point out through some issues
in terms of outcome the earliest studies
people confused with schizophrenia that
was a problem
more recently there been some changes in
the criteria one of the big things that
happened in this country was public law
94-142 back in nineteen seventy four
seventy five I think IDE a law said any
child with special needs walks to the
door is entitled to a free and
appropriate education this was a big
game-changer autism was specifically
mentioned all of a sudden schools had to
provide services before this time
parents could be told by the school we
can't educate this child I'll put them
in where those nice training schools
which is what happened and so kids went
to institutions they learned to
institutions but they didn't get
interventions of the kind that we know
are effective and so this all started to
change with public law 94-142 there's
all kinds of issues in terms of the
methodology and the outcome and if
anybody's interested we can talk about
this if we have time for questions but
I'm just going to sample some data and I
warn you and any time someone and you
pay attention
I'm cherry-picking data i'm
cherry-picking for a good reason i'll
tell you why in a second but these are
data from pat Hollen and elaine imagine
a tease review and 2019 and that book I
mentioned to you from Cambridge
University Press
good outcome means you're so there's
you're out there go on your own you're
self-sufficient we're all outcome means
you have some reliance of the people
usually your parents but you you
checking with people so it's
semi-independent and poor outcome is
your totally dependent and we'll have a
chance to talk about the really good
outcomes because we do have some kids
who have amazingly good outcomes and
these are the first outcome studies and
the reason I cherry pick these this is
I'm going from 56 to 74 why do I stop at
74 because public law 94-142 kicks in so
this is the first set of studies there's
no mandates people are doing the best
job they can bla bla bla but nobody
really knows what they're doing but look
at the number of good outcomes
maybe averaging five percent okay and
poor outcome is probably about two
thirds of cases now we're going to skip
ahead and we're skipping ahead we're
jumping 15 years to let public law
94-142 kick in I'm going from 89 to 2003
I stopped at 2003 because 2004 we had
dsm-4 we include Asperger's that's gonna
make things look better anyway so that's
the reason for this sort cherry-picking
but look at what's happened with the
data the number of good outcome we're
talking 20-25 percent and that's because
we're getting more and better
interventions and there's good reason to
think that as we continue to do this as
we provide interventions earlier we'll
see even more of this and I'll talk
about this again at the end so we think
several factors are involved this change
an outcome first of all the earlier
diagnosis in the intervention we now
have a number of evidence-based
interventions there have been some
changes in diagnostic practice that
might account for some of this because I
showed you these data were really before
DSM 4 so that wouldn't account for most
of it clearly not every child gets
better we have some children and we
can't predict - and it frustrates the
heck out of parents that took a pair of
a two or three year olds how's it going
to do doc I can't tell you I could tell
you four groups of kids I can tell you
these are the things to look for you
will see some children at 2 3 4 years of
age all of a sudden get it and slope
take off like a rocket and it gets bate
amazing to see but you do see it on the
other hand you see some children in good
programs who just stay there they're
like a rock and we can't predict really
who it's possible as now we're starting
to use things like eat cheese and other
things too
look at treatment effects that we may
get better at seeing who does and
doesn't respond to treatments it's a
very interesting issue we have more
embarrassed supports I mentioned
unfortunately there's issues of matching
children to treatment so you have some
children might be great candidates for
ABA they're at each program so again a
lovely program that's not ABA you might
have some kids with you but on a teach
program they're an ABA program so again
this issue of matching kids and
treatments it's very complicated there's
a very good book by Peter drawing called
autism across America which talks about
some of these paradoxes the
interventions 456 to 1980 were basically
unstructured treatments we had some drug
treatments death so many after public
law 94-142 there's all of a sudden great
interest there was a report from the
National Research Council called
educating children with autism that came
out we're actually just redoing this
revisiting educating children with
autism this book from the National
Research Council came out and said
basically educating so with autism is
important we see important change as it
recommended 25 hours of treatment before
kids went to preschool before kids went
to school so it's a big game changer
with 10 programs around the country they
had at least one published study that
shows that their program worked but
again after that there been a really
explosion of evidence-based treatments
and that programs have gotten much
better as as well as the evaluation of
them so we have more and more books on
evaluating evidence-based treatments
there are practice guidelines out there
there's more stuff we know that there
all kinds of approaches to teaching
there are some programs like teach that
are more eclectic and we have ABA
applied behavior analysis we have some
developmental programs like Sally Rogers
kind of kasseri there are more focused
on sort of fostering certain
developmental areas and skills and
finally we have pitbull response which
is a funny comment and interesting
combination of behavioral and
developmental and then they pick certain
areas that they see or pivotal for
enhancing development and they focus
very much on those but in kind of a more
naturalistic ecological way so the gaps
interventional research and especially
for older individuals there is almost no
work there was a paper some years ago
Piven and some of colleagues that
basically said there's no papers on
aging and autism if you read that paper
you've mastered the literature that's no
longer the case we now have the first
time some work going on on this it's a
very interesting area but there's very
limited data we're generalizing a lot
from our work with children adolescents
to our work with adults and older
individuals there's no data looking at
really older very little data looking at
older individuals in autism for example
seizures we assume that maybe an
increased risk for seizure I have a
client might take care of in a group
home is in a 60s and she had her first
seizure and I got a call from the ER up
in Dartmouth where she was at the summer
place that they go to and says she had
the seizure and we agreed she didn't
need to be be tweeting she had only one
seizure she wasn't driving equipment
blah blah blah and he said okay as soon
as she starts to talk I'll I'll release
it from the ER I said well you know I've
done the lady for 25 years and she's
never said a word to me so get ready for
the long haul but it's interesting we
have no data to show what the rates of
seizures are if you look at something
like Down's syndrome it's very different
there's a lot of interest in Down
syndrome and aging because of leukemia
because of Alzheimer's again we just
don't know in autism sadly we're totally
better metrics things like looking more
neurobiological things EEG eye tracking
things even to like you can have
something like turning in response to
prostitue your voice they're much better
than our current approach is our current
approaches to screening and sorry to say
are not horribly effective there was
some data from Norway that shows that
the most commonly used instrument works
about as well as flipping a coin and the
trouble is have over picks up
developmentally disabled and it under
picks up the more able kids with autism
I also just to highlight this if you
look the grey bars or papers being
published in autism the black bars are
papers on intervention in autism
intervention studies are the hardest to
do that hardest to get funded the
hardest to get published if you've ever
been a reviewer or will be a reviewer in
the future you see an intervention study
come through people are although they
were gunning for it somebody in the
review panel will say oh they didn't use
my instrument or they didn't do is
chosen and you know and all this after
that because people are involved and
they'll find some flaw it's like
always hipsters have some some problem
with it and that usually kills that the
feds have been most effective when
they've mandated forced people really to
do a single study and that has actually
been more effective than other things
social policy issues I mentioned it's
very interesting we have essentially
experiments going on in all 50 states
looking at how autism is provided
services sort of childhood and then
schools but nobody's really considered
considering what that is it varies
tremendously I'll sometimes be in the
position of advising people in this
state to move one town to another
because they get better services other
places I will say you know move out of
such and such a move across the river in
different states you get much better
services and it's it's a paradox and
nobody's looked at it and I really can't
say there's no good reason why as I
mentioned there's a good book by Peter
drawing called autism America that kind
of takes up this problem it's also been
to some extent a problem translating
research into practice as you know
anytime we take a research we're
searching intervention out of the field
every single step you kind of get
attrition in terms of how effective the
practitioners are how well-trained they
are how you know faithful they are the
protocol bla bla bla but I think the
other problem is that as researchers we
need to do a better job of taking what
we know from research and explaining to
people and teachers in ways that they
can find helpful and approachable if you
look at the war on web I checked last
night there were over a hundred and
twenty five million hits if you type
autism into Google if you can imagine if
you're a parent doing that what you're
going to be hit with it's a lot even
among the top 100 websites and there are
several published papers on this about a
third of them are either gonna promise
you a cure I asked for money and again
it's a problem but parents you really
need help in terms of finding good
resources oh and I mentioned the online
course this course sure as you heard
this lecture is going to be online it's
got a very substantial viewing which is
great we update it periodically but
having good resources like that
available for free is an important thing
let me just mention very quickly some
general principles of the interaction of
research with clinical work I had as a
patient a fairly high functioning on man
we had several interests
came to be singing when a girlfriend if
we got in two and a half years we got up
a girlfriend we got gonna double-date we
did a whole package of stuff with him it
was great and he came into my office
every day and sat there didn't look at
me usually and we were talking about six
months into it I said you know Joe I
want you to pretend I'm a girl he looked
at me which was unusual looked at he's
dr. Bober I can't pretend you're a girl
you've got a mustache you got a point
here for chrissake and he said why would
I do that I said Joe if you can do that
I will tell you what the girl is
thinking didn't have these big eyes you
can do that anyway and after every
session he was going down and writing
down rules both present one 1:57 vote
versus don't pick your nose girls don't
like it and we got him a girlfriend we
got mister our Chess Club at school he
got some friends he started to go out
and it doubled when a double date was
well the guys from the Chess Club and
they said Joe we gotta take you to
Macy's to get you some new clothes
because you look like a geek and the
kids looks at me says dr. what where do
I look like yeah you look like a key and
go in psychotherapy this populations
very interesting but he said well how
come you look different I said you I'm
gonna tell you something's gonna really
freak you out
what's that I said see my sister's over
there we're gonna cut that top button
off your shirt Joe came in every time no
tie all the buttons are buttoned right
so you'll forgive my saying he looks
like a trailing missionary and he looks
very different from his classmates and
he said I can't do that I'll deface my
shirt my mom'll kill me I said Joe I'm
going to bet you ten dollars right
ten dollars your mom's gonna like it
kids are gonna come at you look
different and so we did it came back in
the next time with ten dollars I don't
know how you knew that
but things like that but again he's very
successfully enrolled so far knock on
wood in a college up in Boston but the
interesting reason for telling this is
while I was working with him and he had
my cell phone number he also had an
interest among other things in the
interchanges under state 95 you know
South Carolina's exit 63 is having
problems with blah blah blah and
Subway's he was interested in subways
and I had to cancel what meaning has I
had to be in Washington for working on
something for the National Research
Council
and it was horrible weather and the
train stopped a couple of times I
checked it's the meeting was going to
happen because they were predicting a
blizzard and Washington which means it's
impossible so I get there six inches of
snow the city shut down you have to pay
$50 just to get into a cab and I slip
and slide to the hotel the next morning
there's no cabs I have to go to the
subway I'm getting on the red line at
Dupont Circle having fought my way
through the snow fought my way through
other people's like the Tokyo subway
following my way in I get in the subway
door the door closes I get a text with
my patient dr. Baltimore don't take the
red line and he was absolutely right ten
minutes later it stopped and there was
some debris on the track or something
but anyway it's interesting every now
and then you see these funny things that
happen and lastly quickly to end with a
happy note Jamie when heartland was join
me in teaching this class we've done it
now for over 30 years these Yale
students who have a seminar and have
lectures but then they go out work in
the school's Chapel Haven been Haven
with people with autism spectrum
disorder and it's an unusual horse for
Yale and as I mentioned its online but
to get in the course because it's
limited for about 20 kids they have to
write me a little essay and the essay is
why they where they are at Yale why
they're taking the course etc etc and
they send it in I have a Teaching Fellow
and I say the Teaching Fellow okay this
is the deal
first take the C here and take the
juniors then take the soft boards then
take the freshmen but if anybody says
they're a sibling take them and every
you'll have a couple of people who were
siblings and I say you know whatever
else is true they should get something
out of because something and so I always
take them and a couple years ago now my
teaching post said you know doctor where
this is not quite what you said but I
want you to read the students essay and
I want to take this because I want to be
a better advocate for people with autism
because I have autism I've never told
anybody yet and so I said okay the kids
in and I got to know him and yeah sure
enough I mean I'm telling with him as a
professor not as a clinician but I can
tell you he sure had autism but it's
very interesting we have more and more
students the last I heard we have five
students at Yale at Southern watch where
I also work part time now we have over I
think 45 students who've identified
which means probably have double that so
more and more kids are going to college
it's
creating some interesting challenges
it's a whole different topic and we're
having a conference as you heard that's
fall hooking by just these transitional
issues but the good news is more and
more people are doing better and better
and we have to now be able to gear up to
service them so that being said the
take-home lesson if you met one person
with autism you've met one person with
autism and so keep that in mind and
since this is Jail I'd hope as a bulldog
I haven't put you to sleep and finally
here's some references up number one up
just for a minute and I'll go to number
two and then we'll be all done and we
can stop the filming and we have three
minutes three minutes for questioning -
whoops okay all done thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you